gun sales have hit a new record so the
Newtown shooting which was in December
of 2012 for the three months after that
you can see a big spike in the three
months following and then for some
reason when it gets a little warmer out
I guess no one buys guns in the in the
middle of the year in towards the summer
and then it goes up again um look you
know this the thing with guns it's like
we something horrible happens and I
think the natural reaction would be to
think that maybe people will be less
interested in guns when when a bunch of
children are shot and yet we have now
all this proof that that's absolutely
not true what is gun sales go up with
people afraid Obama was the Gators all
right so the immediate reaction is a
horrible shooting and then the first
thing that the gun people think is we
have to get more good there's always
going to be reactive people on either
side of an issue so there's reactive
people there like we need to get rid of
all the guns in this country immediately
because children got Sean what about the
children then you're going to have this
complete other reaction which is going
together to take away our guns so let me
just ward all the guns I can and usually
neither those extremes are even relevant
to what's really happening I think
there's a big propaganda machine put out
there by the gun companies mammal
companies and you know everyone else
saying that Obama take them away so
that's why it's dipped a little bit now
I think people realize that Obama's
bigger and better things to do than try
to look wrestle your guns away from you
maybe he wanted more strict background
checks but that's about it yet so wait
so by the way I should say that the the
chart we just showed there was for
background checks so actually the amount
of guns that were bought were really
higher than that because you only need
one background check and goodbye five
guns so what what will it take if
because I do buy into this reactionary
idea both sides immediately after a
tragedy you know stake their claim what
will it take to get some kind of gun
control because that was the chance we
had our chance right after that and
Obama couldn't do it he tried and
couldn't do it and he still is yeah I
mean that's a very important issue and
I'm sure we'll hear about in the state
of the union in three weeks you gotta
remember the National Rifle Association
is driving this engine and I gotta hand
it to them they are very effective in
their messaging and they take no
prisoners so even after the Newtown they
go they're out there scaring people into
buying guns and ammunition which is now
going up we have a serious problem in
this country
and the political leaders are afraid to
tackle it again because the NRA and
those allies they can't even get an
assault weapons ban passed but it's been
expired for 10 years so it's a very sad
state we need we need to concentrate on
that we need to take some action is part
of this also that there's other
political things going on that I think
make the gun people nervous because they
they believe and the NRA believes that
one day they're gonna have to up right
you know have an uprising against the
government I don't know we nearly not
believe that i recommend with the two or
zombies or robots or something but that
so that the more this NSA type stuff
happens it creates more uh suspicions
about the government so it's it's a lot
of things i wanted not just about the
gun it's about things that are actually
legitimately happening in the government
that we're concerned but here's the
thing if you are a reactionary person in
any way in any area of your life you are
an idiot seriously I don't I mean that's
a strong statement and people are gonna
be like why would you say that it's true
if you're a reactive person and you hear
information that you're not sure where
it's coming from and decide to freak out
in the grave immediately oh my god
you're an idiot yeah that's it in that
simple and I think a lot of people you
know it's all personal responsibility
type stuff it's all going ok what's
really going on let me find out the real
information let me find out where it's
coming from and the larger problem this
is no one really cares where everything
is coming from when we hear this type of
information and like you said it's the
gun lobby so we find out how much the
gun lobby has paid for all different
members of Congress paid for people's
campaigns paid for everyone they can't
pass an assault weapons ban how could
you when people are getting so much
money when they're putting food on their
kids tables in the government because
they're getting money from organizations
tides the NRA right okay you know after
after Newtown there was something like
ninety percent people wanted an assault
weapons ban and they still couldn't do
it so that just shows you house and then
RA is very smart politically they'll go
in and if somebody does vote for an
assault weapons ban in their state
they'll recall them oh yeah go out so it
puts the fear of God into these other
politicians are very effective I think
we really have to evaluate the NRA and
maybe start looking at ways to work with
them or to get them to back away or be
aggressive against them if we're going
to look to have any kind of gun
restrictions gun salt weapon ban in this
country yeah is
the bigger thing with the shootings is
it really about prescription drugs this
is the thing that nobody will talk about
with the kids could have any single one
of these mass shooters at cancer it's
every single one a huge percentage i
would venture to say ninety percent in
the last ten years they're always on
prescriptions are generally also either
on antidepressants or something for a DD
or ADHD and both of those drugs have
been shown in kids to you know increased
incidences of suicide murderous thoughts
aggressive thought I listen to the
commercials yeah yeah oh they just you
know this is fully disclosed in the end
of these things could happen to young
adults I think you know the
pharmaceutical industry right now in
this country is and by the way hopefully
maybe they'll get better once they
realize that they can start finding more
and more marijuana things but and I'm
not kidding i say that it's an honest
thing yeah in the pharmaceutical
industry right now is a vested interest
in keeping all the children in this
country on their drugs so then they
become you know users of more of the
drugs they get older and over and over
again and the fact that almost every
single one of these kids involved in a
shooting has been on antidepressant or
on some sort of on you know and feta
mean type ritalin type thing is a huge
problem and no one wants to talk about
it yeah why why won't we is it for the
same reason that we won't do it is
because the NRA and the pharmacy right
there that their lobbies just as
powerful but we just don't hear about
that right its environmental as well
look at the families look at the mother
in the new Townsend situation with
buying her son guns yeah it's it's a lot
I think based on the family I don't
think we can just demonize the
pharmaceutical industry and that parents
are trying to help their kids but I know
families who are very concerned about
their kids cuz they've got these wild
kids and they're not sure what they're
gonna do and it's important that we work
with the families mental health experts
and that there is that health care part
of Obamacare something to to treat
mental health issues in this country is
not just the mass murders but it's so
many other crimes against aside yeah so
last part of this which i think is sort
of what you get to how much of this is
also the media's fall cuz we don't deal
with two things at once ever so shooting
happens we immediately say it's about a
shooting it's about guns but when it
really could be a combination of all the
things we're talking about it could be
at you know the antidepressant it could
be the over violence culture that we
have I don't think it's video games
personally I that to me that's a how you
get the aggression out but that it could
be a confluence of all these things
before we would never have that debate
television certainly doesn't have that
date ever right the television needs to
have sound bites and things now
especially with the internet on there
it's almost a television people are
looking for that one viral hit so they
have the one sentence that explains
perfectly what happened in the holding
or you can't ever examine something as
awful and as as wide as a mass shooting
on just like kid was on Ritalin or you
know bad parents or angry or just a
psychopath or it's always a perfect
storm of things that make something
extreme and terrible like that happen so
when you have a kid going and shooting
somebody and you just don't want to be
insensitive to the families and you also
have to kind of pander to your audience
who needs an answer and wants to feel
safe it's easier just to blame one thing
because then your audience feels like oh
it was just this and if we just take
away guns or if we just take away this
one thing we will never have this again
as we've seen it's never just one
element it's a whole bunch of different
things and I will say I've taken
adderall before I've had to subscribe
for me as you can see I talk really fast
and I have that sometimes built like an
a.d.d type you know personality and it
seriously made me it made me feel like
the most violent crazy thoughts I've
ever felt in my life like rip my own
skin off I feel like my tendency more
would be like to panic myself but I can
imagine if my natural tendency was
toward violence I would have been
violent I'm I've no doubt in my mind
yeah Fred bring us home I just think the
tragedy to is what is going on in this
country think of these schools now that
in when I was growing up we used to have
to go under our desk where to fallout
shelter we thought the nuclear bomb was
coming from Russia now these kids are
fearful of their fellow students they
have locked down where practices law
enforcement works on this security
guards at schools backpack metal
detector searches which is normalizes by
the way this is what's going on in this
country which is terrible kids should
not have to go through that and I think
that's one of the great tragedies of
these gun violence attacks here